first of all uh you know so much has
happened in your life in the last year
we're about to go to comic-con last year
yeah you came with us and you and Moses
storm co-hosted this show for us and I
saw then that you were I'm just sort of
a natural at interviewing people you
just looked like you were very
comfortable interviewing people and I
thought was this something you always
wanted to do no I I was forced to do it
because I worked a lot of jobs mm-hmm
and when you work service jobs you have
to like people even when you don't I
worked out of garden now and I really
said you know that really helps working
at all of garden prepare meeting with
the roof prepared prepared you for your
life and entertainment what do you mean
how did you how did working at all of
garden help you prepare well well first
I got that I've got that job accident I
was high and I was sitting watching TV
and then I was like oh I could go for
some breadsticks right now and in the
week started talking to me the weight
was like yeah but what if you can make
the breadsticks and I ain't see no flaw
on that plan right so I walked into the
Olive Garden I was excuse me sir and I
tapped him on the shoulder and he had
been looking at me the whole time and
and I don't know if you know how awkward
that is to tap somebody on the shoulder
and they have been looking at you said
she was his natural response was I see
you yeah
and then I was like I want two
applications because I will mess up the
first one
any handing me to because he was like at
least he knows that his vision and
leadership and we love that at the Olive
Garden family and the first day I sat
there and I ate bread sticks for 25
minutes and my manager was I know it's a
long time and our manager was like don't
you have tables and I was like man I'm
here our early player and that deserves
a breadstick talk how to be punctual you
know how to fight for what I know and
how to be patient when people want like
a thousand lemons and it in a water but
they don't know lemonade's a thing right
right this was a very good experience
for you
working at the Olive Garden if you early
prepared you yeah it prepared me a lot
man
you